SuperMario run is out now but if you  want to play as more than just  everyone's favorite plumber I've got  good news I'm Tony and this is your  unlockable GameSpot news update  Super Mario run has 5 additional  characters you can unlock easiest to get  is toad who can be unlocked by linking  your my Nintendo account to the game  peach is unlocked when you complete the  game's 24 world tour levels finally you  can get Yoshi toadette and Luigi by  playing enough toad rally races to  unlock their special items in the  kingdom builder mode so you have a few  options there if you don't want to stick  with Mario Super Mario run is free to  download but you'll only get a sampling  of the game's three modes it'll cost you  10 bucks to unlock the full experience  Nintendo has more mobile game plans in  the future including the Animal Crossing  and Fire Emblem series and to keep up  with all of it you're already in the  right place